yeah welcome a new video with black
against them fille de marsay from from
from from Paraguay there are so many
flags with this red white and blue it's
hard to tell them apart so on I went for
the English Defence in 6 p-6 let's start
with B 6 now I know e6 it's an
interesting opening playable against g4
and seafoam and this is some rather
aggressive set up with f3 Black has more
than one interesting way to play against
this the sharpest one is f5 and actually
know a bit about this opening because I
plated sometimes and in tournament chess
and classical time control games the
idea of f5 after he takes a 5 which is
almost exclusively played on the ideas
night to h6 which looks rather weird I
ok I found this book here ok so the idea
is that Bishop h6 that was between each
form at taking only six is also answered
by night f5 now threatening queen h4 and
black and some yeah very much a headed
development why it needs to yeah this is
the best setup he seems to know a bit
about that ok ok it looks it looks
strange black as a pawn down but notice
that d 4 is hanging and he doesn't have
a very natural move to to protect
that's basically only knight to e 2
which completely clocks up his
development white very often those for
long castles here simply because he has
no chance to develop the the clean side
we have 92 as mentioned the only way to
to get some pieces out and now you can
go a knight c6 may be on or other moves
just 97 Queen f6 is also also possible
96 and I'm not sure about the replied d5
it looks a rabbit it looks really crappy
to to open the position even more takes
takes night before how to believe okay
come on get get pieces out this is a
gambit line after all
this I think basically i thought i
thought this forces and the advance that
i wanted to say but he didn't he didn't
comply really so what's what about this
i can take you for now the question is
do I want to or queen to f6 and long
castles ok not let's not think too much
here I actually maybe Queen edge for
first was better haha provoking g3 yeah
I don't think that this is so so much of
a problem can can go to g6 or whatever
doesn't matter so much
huh so if i take on default castle long
but what what about that how does he him
keep the the night now not at all
probably and if i get it back this must
be on a big position with with g 4 and
so on here completely destroyed his
structure k let's go appear threatening
Knight f3
wow I can also take you for now and play
Bishop c5 or yeah and the night is also
I mean what isn't this great position
for Black Knight can also jump to to
various destinations take on an Bishop
c5 is also also looking disastrous
really takes a t5 is also good yeah come
on takes a t5 also very attractive if he
takes e5 no knight c6 winning the the
bishop and he's got a dead bishop on g2
now so let's say here and now I go here
and like a sir yeah it in total command
and he just threw in the towel and maybe
this wasn't even the most forcing way to
play but it's just dreadful what should
should white Play come compass on minus
five it's always funny in those
positions where there's no extra
material for one side yeah it wants to
go king 2 g-3 about what should white
play really so then the age 58 396 a
possible line
yeah just just destruction this this
opening here this is really interesting
the only thing you need to be aware if
you go all the way back is some i played
this against see for you need to become
more cautious if white goes d 4b six
white st form and you don't really want
to do that where you can keep the porn
back but after c4b 60 you make sure that
he's had this move and this is quite
quite good for black I mean it's a
playable interesting opening yeah thanks
for watching this quick win